énergie un plan pour la france charbon
aura sa place avec nous andré giraud
bientôt un revenu minimum garanti pour
les familles 4200 francs à partir de 3
enfants marée noire des bretons à paris
valéry giscard d'estaing les recevra
madame monsieur bonsoir avant de nous
plonger dans l'actualité d'aujourd'hui
voudrais commencer ce journal par un
geste un geste suffisamment admirable
pour qu'il fasse la une de cette édition
l'événement s'est passé il y a moins de
deux heures en direct sur antenne 2 au
cours de l'émission c'est la vie madame
anti g la dernière gagnante du loto qui
a empoché la semaine dernière près d'un
milliard de centimes offert deux chèques
de 250 mille francs chacun l'un à
l'union nationale des myopathes une
maladie très grave des muscles d'autre
part l'autre chèque à l'association
perce-neige qui s'occupe des enfants
handicapés qui est dirigée vous le savez
pas
lino ventura vous propose de revivre
rapidement ce moment très émouvant on
peut lire cette séquence vous remercie
madame quand la myopathie famille qui
connaît pas de chance les jugera que en
partageant la vôtre aujourd'hui je pense
que beaucoup de choses ont changé
maintenant et à l'union des myopathes de
france
nous faisons tout pour aider la
recherche médicale parce que c'est notre
seul espoir c'est de voir qui est
plaisant ajouté chercheurs et on trouve
un remède cette maladie qui est vraiment
terrible
surtout quand elle touche les enfants le
matin j'ai 29 ans quitte en euros
retournez vers l'innovation à que je ne
présenterai pas nécessaire écoutez
madame moi d'abord en mon nom je vous
remercie énormément mais c'est surtout
le tous ses enfants
je voulais un grand mur 5
toute l'attention le plus rapidement
possible d'ouvrir quatre instituts dans
l'hexagone je dire j'aurais que ce soit
quatre instituts qui soit une émulation
pour le reste du territoire
je veux dire que quand bordeaux à
l'institut je voudrais que nice se
demande pourquoi elle n'a pas un je veux
dire oui oui une question serait posée
elle madame c'est pourquoi ce pourquoi
ces dons c'est dire qu'il a donné l'idée
de de faire un tel cadeau aux handicapés
parce que j'ai quatre enfants qui sont
en bonne santé alors j'ai pensé faire
quelque chose pour les enfants malades
l'actualité donc nos lointains ancêtres
avaient l'oeil fixé sur le prix du sel
d'autres plus proches sur le prix de la
pomme de terre les français
d'aujourd'hui ont l'oeil rivé sur le
prix du litre d'essence et plus
généralement de l'énergie parce que
c'est lui qui aujourd'hui détermine
notre niveau de vie quotidien le conseil
des ministres de ce matin avait
justement pour objet de présenter un
plan d'économies d'énergie et de
diversification des sources d'énergie
d'ici à 1990 par exemple le plan prévoit
que le pétrole qui représentait en 1973
deux tiers de la consommation
énergétique française ne représentera
plus en 1990 qu'un tiers pour cela bien
sûr développement maintenu de l'énergie
nucléaire mais aussi développement des
énergies dites vertes barrage solaire
est aussi réactivation de la
consommation du charbon dont le
gouvernement voudrait que l'industrie
multiplient parfum que sa consommation
en visant le charbon il est à peine 10
ans les oracles de l'économie le 10 est
définitivement condamné
au point que sa production est tombé à
20 millions de tonnes aujourd'hui contre
60 millions en 1945 une enquête de
pierre-marie diaby on sait que le
charbon c'est du très vieux bois le
fossile des grandes forêts
préhistoriques se fait banal contient à
la fois tous les avantages et tous les
problèmes du charbon avantage il y en a
des quantités prodigieuse dans le monde
entier
problème depuis si longtemps les
mouvements géologiques ont bouleversé
les sols et les veines de charbon
aujourd'hui encore en 1981
même face à un pétrole hors de prix ce
qui déterminera la survie ou la
fermeture d'une mine
ce n'est pas la quantité de charbon
espérer mais la difficulté de le sortir
ainsi du charbon tout près de la surface
c'est une mine à ciel ouvert une
production rapide massive et bon marché
afrique etats unis sibérie australie etc
ces productions là ont toujours été
concurrentiel elles le seront davantage
dans l'avenir
mais dans les pays qui n'ont pas de
charbon à fleur de sol ou qu'ils ont
déjà épuisé
il faut creuser et plus le charbon est
profond plus il est en couches minces et
fragmentée plus il revient cher depuis
250 ans les techniques d'extraction ont
formidablement progresser les prix de
revient aussi mais on peut aujourd'hui
aller chercher du charbon à des
profondeurs et dans des conditions qu'on
n'imaginait même pas autrefois à la
pointe de ces techniques nouvelles
la gazéification sur place expérimentée
actuellement par les américains est
aussi en france à bruay-en-artois aux
grandes profondeurs plus de 1000 m on ne
sortira même plus le charbon le fera
brûler sur place avec de l'oxygène pour
récupérer un gaz proche du gaz naturel
que l'on transformera ensuite en méthane
si cette méthode s'impose des réserves
utilisables la france passeront de 500
millions à 2 milliards de tonnes reste
un problème qui ne sera jamais
entièrement réglée par la technique et
c'est celui des hommes si les mineurs
ont conquis en deux siècles un statut et
des salaires qui en font une sorte
d'aristocratie ouvrière et l'ont payé
très cher d'éboulement coup de grisou la
légende de la mine a beaucoup paris-xi
la littérature après avoir beaucoup
rempli les cimetières
quant à la civic aux rappelons qu'en
france entre 50 et 100 mille anciens
mineurs demeure atteint dès cette
terrible maladie
il y a là un coût humain qui ne peut
plus être tolérée même et surtout s'il a
été naguère s'ils veulent vivre les
mineurs de fond ne peuvent donc le
rester que quelques années au maximum
cette rotation rapide coûte très cher en
formation et en recyclage et surtout
elle décourage le recrutement par
exemple dans le nord pas de calais le
système ne peut fonctionner que grâce à
une proportion de 70 % d'immigrés qui
rentrent chez eux leur contrat à courte
arm achevée enfin il n'y a pas un
charbon mais des charbons il existe une
infinité de variétés destinées à toutes
sortes d' usage sidérurgie chimie
électricité etc
la production et les marchés sont
différents les prix aussi cet éventail
ajoutée aux variables technique de
l'extraction et aux problèmes humains
peut faire différer les prix de 1 à 20
d'un pays à l'autre et le concurrent du
charbon ce n'est pas seulement le
pétrole c'est le charbon celui du pays
voisin ou même de la mine voisine bien
sûr à l'échelle des besoins énergétiques
de la planète 500 milliards de tonnes de
réserves exploitables à des prix
acceptables
c'est une revanche certaines sur le
pétrole mais cette satisfaction globale
n'a aucun sens à l'échelon national
chaque pays doit raisonner en fonction
de son sous sol national et de ses
propres prix de revient c'est cela qui
va déterminer au coup par coup
puis par puis l'avenir ou la fermeture
des mines de france réactivation de la
consommation de charbon par l'industrie
française cela ne veut pas dire donc
pour autant réouverture ou réactivation
des mines et de la production nationale
cela veut surtout dire augmentation des
importations de charbon et tranchées des
puits vont donc continuer à fermer en
france comme dans le bassin des cévennes
un reportage de jean pétillon le chéneau
termina prospère au charbon très pur
d'un bon rendement qui non j'ai péché
malgré nos efforts malgré nos misères
nous avions pour elle un très grand
amour
ce charbon située rue s'est mis hors
pair
nous aurions voulu toujours fermé saint
jean de valériscle et le martinet le
bassin comptait 21 puis à la libération
il en reste deux fermes et molière et
rochebelle de 21 mille le nombre des
mineurs est tombé à 14 cents la
fermeture se poursuit saint florent en
75 ricard le dernier en 78 le mineur de
fond qui sort de tonnes par jour n'est
pas rentable dit la direction on
n'embauche plus on incite les mineurs à
partir en retraite ou dans d'autres
bassins ou encore à se reconvertir dans
l'industrie une partie ils sont sans
travail en plein air ici à mercoirol où
le rendement est cette fois plus grand
l'objectif c'est 250 mille tonnes par an
soit la moitié de ce qu'on extrait
actuellement dans les cévennes
quant au fond il doit fermer bientôt
avant dernière étape la fin de destival
en mai ces 300 mineurs seront mutés aux
houles l'autre puis 300 mineurs les
survivants d'un puits qui en compte
après 2000 à la conversion de la
biomasse et papy dis ils n'ont pas fermé
encore parce que vous savez les gars
nous sommes pas prêts à l'accepter parce
que le vote jeudi à rennes que tout est
terminé
la veille encore la mer avec l'aide de
l'état subventions prêts spéciaux le
bassin à créer des emplois si milan 20
ans mais il en a perdu treize mille le
plan du grand sud-ouest apporte de
nouvelles aides surtout pour les routes
ainsi 16 millions pour la rocade d'alès
mais aussi pour les logements sans
rénover cette année c'est le productif
qu'il faut aider s'étonnent les cévenols
comme la centrale du fesc qui fournit du
courant à edf
or au lieu de la rénover on veut la
fermer et envoyer le charbon en provence
qui enverra l'électricité à alès où est
la rentabilité
si c'était des industries l'industrie
privée des charbonnages tout récemment à
la ramène en sont privés les capitaux
français les portes la barre à porter il
a la possibilité d'en sortir 2002 5 et
l'altruisme
on nous dit qu'on est pas rentable mais
prenez en france qu'est ce que ces
cadres rentable deux éléments nouveaux
viennent d'intervenir al'avantage des
mineurs les ingénieurs cgc ont calculé
qu'en augmentant la productivité avec de
nouveaux gisements et des mineurs jeunes
les cévennes n'exigerait qu'une
subvention de 120 francs par tonne et
non 400 francs sur les bases de la
direction quant aux élus de la région
qui se mobilisent ils ont voté des
crédits pour ouvrir une nouvelle mine
ladrech tu es inciter l'état à convertir
au charbon plusieurs centrales de la
région
oui cela dit il y a des cas quand même
où les effets conjugués de la hausse du
prix du pétrole et la découverte de
techniques nouvelles permettent de
redonner leur chance à certaines
exploitations minières comme la mine de
gardanne dans les bouches du rhône où
l'on vient même de découvrir un nouveau
gisement
un reportage de patricia cost c'est un
cas la petite mine de gardanne à 15 km
au sud d'aix en provence à l'ombre de
fos sur mer sous le printemps le plus
précoce de france est là la productivité
pour mineurs la meilleure de france
mineurs font pas très bien de faire un
bon miller en province
j'en prend 2% la preuve qu'on est arrivé
à mécaniser quand même une autre mine
aux enfants et si on est arrivé à faire
cette mécanisation c'est que les
meilleurs en province sont bons et parce
que ben ils disent encore ce qu'on
cherche c'est de travailler avec la tête
avant notre oreiller avec les bras une
mine où l'on a le goût de
l'expérimentation paraît-il mais aussi
un terrain qui s'y prêtent des galeries
comme des boulevards des veines droite
sont trop de cassure épaisse pour un
rabot qui a pas le changement
un plafond marchand qui soutient terrain
des mineurs spécialisé en hydraulique en
électronique presque satisfait moi la
réponse est des équipes qui feront rien
et l'équipe si elle est pas soudé ça
marche pas vraiment les automatismes on
a manqué beaucoup de machines ans et ça
simplifie la tâche mais malgré tout
c'est pas déshumanisé pour ça il y est
toujours mais disons qu'il est beaucoup
moins de monde et vous vous avez peur de
deux auteurs ça m'est arrivé en date
mènerait j'ai plus pur mais est-ce que
c'est plus dur de descendre vos fous
quand on a un pays comme ça au dessus de
la tête
c'est pas tous les jours un dollar sur
toute attitude une chose certaine elle
au soleil
c'est difficile et qui selon pierre on a
retrouvé charbon à 1000 mètres de
profondeur des sondages ont permis de
retrouver la course sur plus de 40
kilomètres carrés il s'agit d'une très
belle couche quand c'est dont on connaît
l'existence et jusqu'à l'étang de berre
puisque des sandales des pétroliers
avaient permis de la retrouver
c'est un cas les mine de gardanne on va
donc y ouvrir un puits sur le nouveau
gisement ce qui ne s'est pas vu en
france depuis 25 ans ce nouveau chantier
va créer des emplois pour un millier de
personnes tandis qu'à la mine on
embauche déjà 120 personnes par an pour
600 demandes essentiellement des gens du
terroir une seule maison sera
éventuellement touchés et encore ce
n'est pas sûr
tout ça pour une centrale thermique à
500 m de là alimenté comme par un cordon
ombilical en charbon un mauvais charbon
il faut le dire si mauvais que gardanne
a bien failli fermer il ya 20 ans bien
avant d'autres mines
si l'on n'avait pas eu l'idée de cette
centrale mangetout et les anciens
veulent voir dans cette histoire une
morale il faudrait donner la possibilité
aux ingénieurs et aux directions des
autres mines de faire preuve
d'imagination pour faire durer la mine
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui s'est passé ici
où nous avons été malheureux une
certaine époque où ils ont fait preuve
tout le monde fait preuve d'imagination
d'où un défi nitive même en ayant un
petit peu temps telle aventure
nous sommes arrivés à des résultats la
dernière aventure qui est tentée n'est
pas dit qu'elle ne présente de rapa d'un
comédien mêmes faits
d'ici nous sommes heureux c'est vrai
mais ça nous ce qui nous attriste ce
savoir qu ailleurs les mines doivent
fermer la centrale aussi va grossir 600
mégawatts dans quatre ans la plus grande
de france
thaler en arrivant sur ce plateau
monsieur le ministre vous nous avez dit
comme tous les autres journalistes qui
vous a le plus frappé c'est mes propos
sur le charbon
alors si j'ai bien compris tout ce qu'on
vient de dire cette réactivation de la
consommation de charbon en france est
avant tout un plan d'importation de
charbon
disons que dans la mesure où nous
dépendons exagérément du pétrole nous
devons utiliser tous les moyens de nous
en passer et le charbon en est un que
nous allons donc utiliser autant qu'il
est possible de toute façon nous sommes
importateur de charbon à l'heure
actuelle nous importons 30 millions de
tonnes alors que nous produisons que 20
millions de tonnes donc ce n'est pas un
problème nouveau
nous devrons simplement faire attention
à ce que ces importations se passe dans
de bonnes conditions alors s'agissant de
la production nationale je crois que les
reportages que vous avez passé ont dû
faire parfaitement saisir aux
téléspectateurs les vrais problèmes de
lecture marque parce qu'avant d'être
ministre d'industrie vous avez été
ingénieur des mines si oui mais enfin je
vais je n'ai pas gelé guère d'expérience
du charbon personnellement mais je crois
qu'on a très bien compris les vrais
problèmes il ya tout d'abord bien
entendu un problème financier
nous pouvons apporter une certaine
préférence notre charbon nationale mais
comme il est payé par le contribuable
chacun comprend très bien quelle de ceux
ci ne peut pas être illimitée et
d'ailleurs vous avez vu à quel point les
mineurs sont même sensible au problème
du prix de revient
c'est donc un premier une première
question d'autre part il ya également
des questions humaines
on vous a expliqué qu' une partie de nos
réserves n'étaient pas exploitables par
des moyens humains qu'il fallait donc
chercher des procédés technologiques
pour le faire et puis on a également
indiqué dans une des mines qu' il
faudrait embaucher des jeunes et que
c'était le seul moyen d'exploiter le
charbon qui restait pour quelque temps
encore alors qu à gardanne on commence
juste et pour longtemps et on se rend
compte que l'exploitation charbonnière
française ne peut pas se dérouler avec
une politique du personnel qui soit trop
morcelé avec des endroits où on met les
gens à la retraite et d'autres non
embauche il faut qu'ils aient vraiment
une politique du personnel cohérente
c'est sous ces réserves là que nous
sommes très favorables au développement
du charbon est le cas de garda nous
montre que en faisant l'inventaire du
charbon nous trouverons peut-être des
ressources et nous n'avons pas le droit
de négliger cette possibilité mais à
l'armée sioniste ce plan présenté
aujourd'hui prévoit une diversification
donc des sources d'énergie c'est
peut-être un petit peu le rattrapage des
erreurs du passé du tout pétrole qu'on
avait proposé à partir des années 1960
on sait je crois qu'il ne faut pas trop
critiquer les prédécesseurs
et si à l'époque on avait proposé à
l'industrie française d'utiliser une
énergie beaucoup plus cher que le
pétrole en la pénalisant ainsi dans la
concurrence internationale par exemple
au moment où l entrée dans le marché
commun on aurait certainement reprocher
au gouvernement de le faire donc à
l'époque l'emploi du pétrole étaient
peut-être judicieux
depuis nous constatons que la situation
internationale s'est dégradée et nous
essayons de réduire notre dépendance
pétrolier s'est dit aujourd'hui le parti
socialiste par exemple qui vous posent
aujourd'hui vous le savez sans doute 30
questions sur notre politique
énergétique et à prix il a fait une
conférence de presse pour me dire qu'il
allait me les poser je vais alors parmi
celles ci le parti socialiste vous
reproche de promouvoir aujourd'hui le
tout nucléaire bien les états c'est une
idée fixe
n'est ce pas le parti socialiste qui n'a
pas été capable jusqu'ici de présenter
un programme énergétique et qui d'après
ce que j'entends dire de cette
conférence de presse a annoncé que
peut-être dans quelques mois il pourrait
le faire
s'obstine à parler du tout nucléaire
contre toute vraisemblance je vous
renvoie au chief en 1990 à une époque où
le nucléaire ce sera beaucoup développée
par rapport à aujourd'hui nous ne
représente que 4 et demi pour cent de
notre approvisionnement énergétique ne
représentera encore que 30 % à côté d'un
pétrole qui malheureusement représentera
en
or 30 % mais est ce que vous pensez
comme le demandent aussi le parti
socialiste qu'on peut organiser un débat
par exemple au parlement sur ce problème
mais on ne cesse de dépasser organiser
des débats et monsieur qui laisse vous
avez mis en cause tout à l'heure qui est
le porte parole du parti socialiste n'a
pas jugé opportun d'employés la totalité
de son temps de parole au dernier débat
qui avait été ouvert l'assemblée
nationale sur le sujet bien alors les
énergies vertes maintenant vous prévoyez
dans un premier temps qu'elle fournirait
5% de l'énergie en 1980 dans l'an 2000
pardon vous dites aujourd'hui que vous
pourriez arriver à ces 5 % dès 1990
alors qu'est ce que vous allez faire
pour développer ces énergies oui je
crois que il est important que nous ne
donnions pas de faux espoirs aux
français et nous n'avons pas annoncé des
miracles dans les débuts du programme
relatif aux énergies nouvelles
nous constatons aujourd'hui que certains
des perspectives qui avait été entrevu
au début se sont fermées mais que
d'autres au contraire se sont davantage
ouverte et ceci nous permet d'avoir une
politique volontariste grâce à laquelle
10% de notre bilan énergétique de 90
sera due aux énergies renouvelables
l'hydraulique et pour la moitié les
énergies dites nouvelles alors deux
dernières questions de ce giro il semble
que vous ayez des problèmes pour arriver
à économiser des 45 millions de tonnes
d'équivalent pétrole que vous aviez
prévu pour 85
mais malgré cela vous dit que vous allez
économiser encore plus alors sur quoi
peut-on encore économiser aujourd'hui ce
qu'on n'a pas fait le plus gros nom nous
n'avons pas de problème les 45 millions
de tonnes avaient été évaluées à une
époque où la croissance économique était
très rapide et par conséquent aux frais
de grandes reste de grandes possibilités
ce chiffre avait été ensuite rajusté en
fonction de la croissance économique à
35 millions de tonnes et non seulement
nous tenons ce programme nous sommes
même en avance parce que les français
ont compris et qu'effectivement il se
prête pour le méconnu mines énergie
alors qu'allons nous faire bien
essentiellement une action sur l'habitat
qui va être beaucoup plus intense non
seulement sur l'habitat nouveau mais sur
l'habitat ancien une action de
reconversion dans l'industrie et
d'économie d'énergie également dans
l'industrie très efficace par exemple 60
milliards de francs seront consacrés aux
économies d
et dans l'industrie et puis nous
continuerons aussi à diminuer la
consommation unitaire des voitures en
essayant de ne pas trop
les ont perturbé la vie des français
alors justement on en arrive à la vie
des français tout ce que vous dites là
peut être mis en cause demain par une
augmentation des prix de l'opep ou bien
par exemple par un cours du dollar plus
fort non ça me les ont mis en cause au
contraire le bien fondé de cette
politique réduisant la dépendance
pétrolière ne serait ce serait
simplement accrue oui mais par exemple
je parle de 10 $ qui est à plus de 4
france 5 entre son nom c'est avec ça que
nous payons pétrole alors est-ce que
c'est l'heure du dollar hier plus ils
seraient au portugal à ce que je lui ai
promis mais est ce que ça veut dire par
exemple que si le cours du dollar
continue à monter on va payer plus cher
les sens c'est toujours la dernière
question qu'on vous pose un gars
brillant et sanguinaire pas de miracle
je vois pas très bien qui en dehors des
consommateurs pourraient payer la hausse
du prix du pétrole
mais on parle par exemple si si les
choses continuent comme en ce moment
d'un prix de 7 francs en france
d'aujourd'hui du prix du litre de super
en 1990 alors avec des conséquences
industrielles et économiques sur le pays
on peut jeter n'importe quels chiffres
en l'air je suis dans l'incapacité
totale et vous me comprendrez de dire
combien vaudra l'essence en 1990 donc le
ministre d'industrie en 1981 n'est pas
un ministre remplit certitude arrache
certainement pas c'est d'ailleurs une
des difficultés du problème merci
monsieur giraud toujours au conseil des
ministres ce matin les ministres ont
examiné un projet de loi visant à
instituer un revenu minimum familiale en
faveur des familles dans de plus de
trois enfants le projet a été adopté il
concerne 150 mille familles et cinq cent
mille enfants
la loi sera examiné au mois de mai par
le parlement elle devrait garantir un
revenu minimum de 4200 francs pour une
famille de trois enfants
isabelle le cher pour ce qu'il est
convenu d'appeler les smicards ce revenu
minimum prendra la forme d'une indemnité
différentielle c'est à dire qu'on se
fendra sur l'ensemble des revenus de la
famille salaires et allocations
confondues et que les caisses
d'allocations familiales feront le
complément à concurrence de 4200 francs
pour les familles modestes revenus ou
moins réguliers l'allocation sera
forfaitaire et dépassera à peine les 200
francs par mois les associations
familiales sont mécontentes de cette
mesure
un exemple des 78 l'unaf considéré que
le minimum
et sans pour une famille de trois
enfants était de 5000 francs par mois
manufrance la paye de mars n'ayant pas
été versés encore les salariés de
l'entreprise ont occupé ce matin le
siège de stéphanois de la bnp la banque
et se sont mises en grève l'occupation
de la banque nationale de paris a pour
objet de protester selon les syndicats
contre le refus des banques de
travailler avec manu france ce qui met
en péril le redressement de la société
et puis ce soir à la sncf cinq
fédérations de cheminots ont signé
l'accord salarial pour 1981 mais la cgt
et la cfdt ont refusé leur signature cet
accord selon ces deux centrales est trop
éloignée des véritables revendications
des cheminots c'est ce que disent la cgt
et la cfdt
comme on pouvait le craindre le coup de
filet du week end dernier des polices
française et italienne n'a pas mis un
terme aux activités des brigades rouges
ni à celle du groupe action directe en
france
la nuit dernière un attentat des
brigades rouges dans un local de la
démocratie chrétienne a fait quatre
blessés à milan en france par contre le
groupe action directe menace de
parlementaires messieurs jean foyer et
jacques piot respectivement président et
vice président de la commission des lois
à l'assemblée nationale le correspondant
anonyme qui leur a téléphoné les a
menacés de punition qui pour prouver
l'existence du groupe action directe
monsieur jacques piot a déjà réagi à ces
menaces en déclarant qu'il ne craignait
pas les nazillons c'est ce qu'il a dit
signaler que les 19 personnes
interrogées par la police judiciaire sur
les activités du groupe action directe
ont été déférés ce soir devant la cour
de sûreté de l'état au tchad est les
combats ont redoublé de violence
aujourd'hui les partisans de monsieur
hissène habré ont visiblement pris
l'offensive
ils ont pénétré dans les faubourgs de la
capitale jammin après la tuerie des
obsèques de monseigneur romero dimanche
dernier au salvador le gouvernement fait
porter la responsabilité de la fusillade
à l'extrême gauche et il en profite pour
prolonger l'état de siège dans le pays
cette version des faits n'est pas
partagé par les représentants de
l'église catholique présents à
l'enterrement
c'est le cas notamment l'archevêque de
reims monseigneur ménagers qui
aujourd'hui à son retour en france a
expliqué en exclusivité pour antenne 2 à
berne a rappelé que selon lui mais aussi
selon les autres religieux présents
dimanche au salvador la fusillade est
plutôt amer
trop content de l'autre bord
c'est-à-dire de l'extrême droite
ils estiment très franchement que
l'origine de la panique vient de la
police où vient des groupes d'extrême
droite
la presse reconnaît elle même qu'il y
avait des tirs des francs-tireurs
d'extrême droite dans toutes les maisons
face à la place et j'avais vu le matin
même en arrivant en avion une la prensa
de mexico et qui annonçait sur un titre
est o comme ça que les autres les
francs-tireurs d'extrême droite avait
promis de tirer sur les catholiques
qu'ils se rassembleraient pour
l'enterrement de monseigneur romero
les gens me paraissait tranquille quand
je suis passé dans la rue près de la
cathédrale
je voyais des files entières de jeunes
le poing levé n'est ce pas et qui en
même temps s'arrêtait de lever le poing
pour applaudir visiblement le discours
du cardinal raum ada qui finissait son
homélie
j'arrivais donc sur la place sa course
d'avions en retard je suis arrivé en
retard
j'arrivais sur la place avec mon ob ce
qu'il fallait pour participer et là j'ai
vu à un 150 m cette bombe éclate et est
immédiatement des coups de feu et une
panique terrible je me suis dit voilà
des gens qui ont l'habitude d'être
attaqué ou d'avoir des des coûts' jantes
les otages américains de l'ambassade de
téhéran ce soir c'est la confusion la
plus complète la maison blanche
elle-même ne semble plus comprendre ce
que réclame le gouvernement iranien et
on ne sait plus très bien non plus si
les otages vont rester sous le contrôle
des étudiants islamiques ou passer sous
celui du gouvernement iranien
on ne sait pas non plus exactement quel
est maintenant la position exacte de
l'imam coming cette affaire dans
laquelle les intérêts américains sont
malmenés pour le moins n'a pas empêché
monsieur caractère de remporter de
nouvelles élections primaires contre
monsieur kennedy dans le wisconsin dans
le kansas du côté républicain
le vainqueur est sans conteste ronald
reagan
en grande bretagne la grève dans la
sidérurgie qui durait depuis trois mois
et dont nous vous avions déjà longuement
parlé c'est terminé enfin aujourd'hui le
2 avril 1974 mouret le président georges
pompidou des suites d'une très grave
maladie cet anniversaire correspond à la
sortie de plusieurs livres expliquant
les relations de monsieur pompidou avec
le général de gaulle
le prêtre qui a célébré
matin une messe anniversaire en l'église
saint-louis à paris en présence
notamment de messieurs chirac et chaban
delmas a d'ailleurs évoqué ces
polémiques sur l'attitude du président
pompidou vis-à-vis du général de gaulle
une polémique regrettable at il dit et
c'est ce que pense aussi d'ailleurs
monsieur michel jobert l'un des
collaborateurs les plus proches de
monsieur georges pompidou
monsieur pompidou était un homme solide
était un homme direct
c'était un homme sage et je crois que
pour le résumer par rapport au public et
je crois que c'est comme ça que le
public l'a ressenti c'était un homme de
bon sens que son bon sens ne paralyse et
pas c'est à dire que quand l'heure de la
décision était venu il la prenait il
prenait ses responsabilités et il les
assume et je crois que c'est peut-être
cette image là dans un univers très
informatisée recrue d'information qui
restera dans le public
un homme bien de chez lui les pieds sur
terre la tête claire et qui savait en
toutes circonstances ce qui était
possible de demander au pays ce qu'il
était possible de lui demander au titre
d'un certain dépassement
selon l'hebdomadaire le canard enchaîné
qui publie aujourd'hui la police avec
monsieur jean de braye l'ancien ministre
général de gaulle assassiné le 24
décembre 1973 pardon était menacé de
mort cette information parue aujourd'hui
remet à jour une affaire dont
l'instruction venait justement d'être
close le point sur cette affaire avec
françois cante quatre services de police
savait c'est maintenant officiel que
jean de braye était menacée 10e brigade
territoriale renseignements généraux
brigade antigang l'inspection générale
des services la police des polices et
jean dutrey directeur de la police
judiciaire aurait reçu un premier
rapport d'inspecteurs de la 10ème
brigade territoriale en date du 1er
avril 76 les informant qu'un trafic de
faux bons du trésor imprimé dans le midi
de la france allait être dé distribuer
sur le marché et que ce trafic allait se
déclencher sur la liste des
investigateurs un avocat du barreau de
paris et un gros bonnet de la politique
six mois plus tard
nouveau rapport aux mêmes destinataires
et des noms l'avocat marc ben moha le
gros bonnet jean de braye député de
l'eure et messieurs 2 varga et a le nez
de rythme en tout deux propriétaires de
la rôtisserie la reine pédauque à paris
a dit jean de braye avait prêté 4
millions de francs pour acheter cet
établissement ce n'est pas tout d'après
le second rapport jean de braye et
menacé de mort il aurait commis une
indélicatesse portant sur plusieurs
millions de francs il doit être exécuté
dans les prochains jours filature par la
police des coupables présumés et le 24
décembre 1976 jean de braye est abattu à
la sortie d'un immeuble rue des
dardanelles à paris par un petit truand
gérard frêche
guy simonet un inspecteur principal
aurait organisé le crime commandité par
deux varga qui nie les policiers ont
cessé de protéger jean de braye depuis
le 8 décembre une quinzaine de jours
avant le crime
pourquoi c'est bien sûr la question
posée il y en a une autre qui trouve
peut-être ce soir une réponse
selon le canard enchaîné ces deux
rapports de police n'ont jamais été
transmis au juge chargé de l'instruction
de cette affaire
jean dutrey le directeur de la police
judiciaire qui n'avait rien à déclaré ce
matin sur ces informations
annoncé tout à l'heure que ces
renseignements contenus dans les
rapports qui existent bien avait été
verbalement porté à la connaissance du
juge d'instruction dès le début de l'
enquête
pourquoi ce dossier at il alors été
fermée le 21 mars dernier sans que les
mobiles du meurtre de jean de braye
n'ait été élucidé mais justement à
l'occasion de l'ouverture de la session
de printemps du parlement monsieur
gaston defferre a demandé du parti
socialiste à demander la réouverture de
l'instruction de la sphère de breuil à
la lueur de ces informations nouvelles
le parti communiste lui a annoncé par
l'intermédiaire du président de son
groupe parlementaire me balanger qu'il
allait déposer une proposition de loi
pour permettre une meilleure
transparence de la vie politique
française
une proposition qui intervient après l
affaire du passé de monsieur georges
marchais un sondage pour en terminer
avec la politique
la publication écologique le sauvage
publie un sondage indiquant que 27% des
français interrogés seraient prêts à
voter pour un candidat écologique au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle en 1981 et puisque nous
parlons d'écologie les victimes
du naufrage du pétrolier et agneaux
seront indemnisés le plus rapidement
possible et dans les meilleures
conditions c'est ce qu'a indiqué
aujourd'hui la mission
interministérielle de la mer ce même
jour près de 600 élus bretons marins
pêcheurs et représentants des
organisations touristiques bretonnes
sont venus manifester à paris devant la
chambre des députés et puis ensuite
devant l'elysée elles ont été déçus de
ne pas avoir été reçu par le président
lui-même aucun incident n'a marqué cette
manifestation il semble même qu'il y ait
eu un petit malentendu à propos de cette
réception par le président de la
république qui déclare ce soir un
communiqué l'elysée le président de la
république est prêt à rencontrer les
élus bretons sur les problèmes de la
marée noire
cette réunion d'aujourd'hui avec un
collaborateur du président qu'on
refusait les élus bretons étaient
justement destinés à préparer cette
réception des élus bretons par le
président de la république lui-même nous
allons maintenant si vous le voulez bien
faire le point sur place avec henri gal
et sur le front de la marée noire 2500
militaires dans les côtes du nord 800
dans le finistère procèdent à
l'évacuation des résidus pétroliers
un peu plus de trois semaines après le
naufrage du tanio 3000 tonnes de mazout
ont été ainsi récupérer les observations
faites par le sous-marin de poche
envoyés sur les lieux ont permis de
constater que la partie avant du tanio
continué à fuir de façon irrégulière une
1,7 tonne par jour actuellement la
direction du vent et du courant est
favorable et le pétrole reste localisée
au large autour de l'épave
on estime aujourd'hui à environ 8000
tonnes ce qui reste de mazout dans les
cuves du pétrolier pour terminer une
bonne nouvelle le sport la victoire cet
après midi au tournoi de tennis de monte
carl du français caujolle contre l'un
des tout premiers joueurs mondiaux j'ai
nommé l'américain jimmy connors ce
n'était pas n'importe qui et puis on se
porte toujours victoire du hollandais
l'ubs erding dans la classique cycliste
gand wevelgem et puis ce soir bien sûr
peut-être la plus importante journée de
championnat de football de première
division avec un certain saint-etienne
monaco dont vous aurez les résultats
bien sûr et peut-être des images dans
notre dernier journal avant de vous
donner la météo
je voudrais si je me retrouve vous
donner les pronostics est d'abord de
pierrette brès pour le tiercé de demain
vous allez voyez apparaître sur votre
écran le
le 2 3 le 9 le 13 le 6 le cese pardon le
7 et le 12
et puis les résultats du loto avec
peut-être je ne sais pas je n'ai pas les
chiffres mais peut-être un milliardaire
pourquoi pas encore cette semaine le 6
le 19 le 26 le 29 le 30 et le 41 numéro
complémentaire
7 voici maintenant à la météo de demain
temps prévu sur la france pour la
journée de jeudi de la haute normandie
et du nord vosges et à la savoie le
temps sera variable et frais avec des
averses sur les autres régions
après une matinée fraîche et parfois
brumeuse des éclaircies deviendront de
plus en plus belles et les températures
remonteront sensiblement voilà dernier
journal pierre-alain en fin de programme
demain invités d'antenne 2010 georges
séguy demain soir à 20 heures
un reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
bernard benyamin et patrice du top que
vous conseille de regarder et qui ont
partagé pendant quelque temps la vie des
rebelles afghans qui combattent les
troupes soviétiques
bonsoir